on geologic oops I'm distributing data
I'm fully in America City right so
thanks for coming I'm really happy to be
here to tell you about some joint work
with Dan a let's NIV and you've all and
I'm gonna give the first piece of this
talk on zero knowledge proof some
distributed data and then let's gonna
talk about some applications to
multi-party computation other things so
we've seen already zero knowledge proof
I'm not gonna bore you to death with the
definitions but I just want to give you
the picture so that I can give you the
contrasting picture on the next slide so
think of a proof or in a verifier and
think of approver with a graph trying to
convince a verifier who has the same
graph that this graph is 3 colorable so
of course we want these protocols to
satisfy natural notions of completeness
and soundness and zero knowledge and so
in this talk we're actually not going to
be looking at this type of protocol
we're gonna be looking at it's kind of a
twist on the the normal setting in which
we have multiple verifiers and now each
verifier is only going to take as input
a piece of the graph so the prover has
has the entire graph and knows the three
coloring and is going to try to convince
the verifiers that hold this graph in
distributed fashion that the the graph
that they're holding together is 3
colorable so we have different notions
of completeness and soundness and zero
knowledge now so now completeness means
that an honest provers should convince
an honest pair of verifiers that the
graph is 3 colorable soundness means
that a cheating proofer should rarely
fool an honest pair of verifiers so say
they all reject yeah yeah and zero
knowledge here means that if either one
of the verifiers in the setting is is
cheating as deviating from the protocol
the only thing that it learns is its
input and the fact that the entire graph
is 3 colorable so in particular verifier
v1 shouldn't learn anything else about
this graph G 2 apart from the fact that
it's sort of part of a 3 colorable graph
yes yes so I should have said the the
prover is going to interact with both of
the verifiers and the verifiers can
interact with each other and they can
even share say common randomness so so
using whatever the beautifies can learn
by tracking alone
but whatever there's it that's that's a
sense of what they can learn with
attractive of the truth that 7zu yes and
other vampires information so the
question is so your question is why
don't why can't these verifiers just
simulate yeah so you might lose this
zero knowledge or privacy property so if
v1 sends its peace its piece of the
graph to the other verifier this
verifier now can simulate the sort of
one verifier setting but now v2 has
learned this piece of the graph which is
essentially what we're trying to hide so
there is this line of communication
between them every Friday looks like so
the honest verifier will not do this so
all I'm saying is is yeah so if one of
the verifiers is dishonest then that
dishonest verifier doesn't wear anything
else good as I've defined it here though
yeah exactly
no verifiers dishonest and then you get
no guarantees so yeah so I guess the
reason the reason we call it strong zero
knowledge is that the verifier is each
verifier doesn't neither very far
actually learns the graph itself so it
learns that it's it's it's learned that
it's sort of together they're holding a
3 colorable graph but neither verifier
actually knows what the graph is so it's
kind of stronger than the usual notion
of zero knowledge
any other questions about the southern
yeah distributed computing will say
dishonest very five isn't dinner in
peace until case there is no meaning of
his part of the graph because it can lie
about it and have anything so what is
the pinnacles we color on that so right
so your question is if this a verifier
v2 is Byzantine what does it mean for I
mean so these notions of completeness
and soundness still make sense in the
Byzantine cases just hear the verifiers
are gonna be honest right so I've said
that completeness means an honest prove
or convinces an honest pair of our virus
and same for soundness in the
zero-knowledge case I it doesn't
actually matter whether v1 is Byzantine
or not all it's saying is that no matter
how v1 deviates from the protocol it
can't learn anything beyond the input
that I gave it and the graph the fact
that the graph is 3 colorable yeah but
so so I see I see I mean this g2 that
you're saying like the g2 that I gave is
input to verify our v2 it doesn't have
to read the input but yeah
but in that you can obviously emulate
the protocol so different that you
choose
right but that's that's not sort of
violating the definition of zero
knowledge that I've set up here if
you're private for the particular g2
yeah you too history Cobra for the
particular G to them you can switch to
different YouTube so I guess I'm not
maybe I'm not understanding your
question clearly just saying that if you
insist on v2 that's a particular graph G
to be to choose a different graph G to
that he likes and runs the protocol on
stay above that yeah yeah yeah no so
this so so so the yeah the protocol will
always reject in that case so basically
so what this is saying is is that for
this particular g2 that g1 plus g2 the
particular graph that we're splitting up
and giving to these verifiers this is
ones your knowledge holds I will not
that you can reverse engineer the formal
definition yes I thought you say to do
there's very fine can be corrupted no
you say the truth can be corrupted so
for different properties I'm requiring
different different things to hold so if
the provers if everybody's honest
then the verifiers except if the prover
is cheating then honest verifiers will
reject a false proof and here I'm saying
that a cheating verifier doesn't learn
anything about the graph that it's not
supposed to learn
so so this is this is uh yeah it's a
twist on the regular setting guarantee
of the provers cheating and one of the
verifies that's right
yeah so so actually we do talk about
that extension the paper because we're
already confused enough then I'm gonna
yeah but but you you can definitely look
at the setting in which some yeah
majority of the verifiers are honest but
so yeah so so there's lots of extensions
that you can look at okay but right so
you can also look at sort of multi
ground protocols public line protocols
protocols with more than than two
verifiers and to make things even more
complicated a loans gonna talk tomorrow
about a different setting of zero dollar
proofs with multiple verifiers
but i'm not going to go into that other
notion of distributed verified proof
okay so particularly interesting setting
for zero knowledge proof son distributed
data is when the input is split amongst
multiple verifiers
using secret sharing so this comes up in
MPC like oh that's going to talk about
another application so you can think of
the prover as having a vector X and the
verifiers each have additive shares of
this vector and they're trying to be
convinced that that these short shares
add up to a vector in a language so if
you you know just so you've seen this
for the first time it's not obvious why
this should be useful at all and
particularly you might think this is
sort of a cooked up problem that I made
just to solve but it turns out there's a
number of applications in cryptographic
protocols and other things so I'll just
give one application to explain why this
is interesting so imagine a system in
which you have multiple database servers
and each server holds say a linear
secret sharing of a database and we'd
like a client to be able to increment
one row of this database that's held
that secret shared fashion across the
servers without revealing to the
server's which row the client is
updating so what the client can do is it
can take its database update so so it
wants to increment say the third row of
the database it can split this update
vector into two shares and send one
share to each of the two servers and the
server's can add this update vector into
their sort of shares of the database
yeah and this will have the effect of
incrementing the secret sure database by
one and we'd like to be guaranteed that
even if the client cheats even if the
client sends garbage to the servers that
still the client should only be able to
update one row of the database so with
this require
as us to do is have the client sort of
proved to the servers that these updates
that it's sent essentially add up to a
low weight of a vector of wave 1 so this
is a proof on distributed data so this
thing is actually used today on the
Firefox browser for collecting telemetry
data from the browser and a
privacy-preserving way this ships with
the browser and is used by millions of
people every day and as far as I know
this is the world's largest deployment
of PCP based technology so it's like
even though it seems kind of contrived
that actually has a number of
applications like this yeah any
questions so far
okay so right so there's a number of
other applications that I'm not gonna
have time to talk about 2pir writing and
private messaging private statistics
private ad targeting and so on and the
language is that these systems need to
work with are often very simple so low
weight vectors low norm vectors and so
on these journals proofs on distributed
data that were constructed implicitly in
these prior systems all had
communication costs that scaled linearly
with the size of the vectors so linear
size proofs and in this work we show how
to reduce the size of these or the
amount of communication to either
constant or logarithmic in that in a
dimension of the vectors and all that's
going to talk about MPC applications as
well just I happen to know that you can
do multi-party computation that aside
from whether something that you learn
total output you didn't need to learn
anything about so if I take note about
the computation to zero knowledge of the
steps of the multi-party computation
white is not essentially solved wrong
that's a great question so I'll let
Alette answer this question because it's
a yeah but because otherwise we'll start
talking about MPC and then yeah we won't
get anything else so okay so so what I'm
going to show is that if a.length you
have a language L in question that's
recognized by circuits of size C then
there's a public coin zero knowledge
proof on distributed data for this
language that has a constant number of
rounds and communication costs that
grows linearly with the size of the
circuit so this generalizes some sort of
special purpose
that were used or constructed implicitly
in the literature and we give some
non-trivial extension to the setting
that Nick asked about where the prover
and some of the verifiers collude the
second type of result we have is about
kind of simple languages so if your
language is degree two has a degree two
arithmetic circuit then there's a proof
on distributed data for this language
that has logarithmic leap many rounds of
communication and logarithmically much
communication cost so this is kind of an
exponential savings when your language
is simple and this extends to kind of K
round protocols with slightly worse
communication cost and applies much more
generally to kind of languages with with
structure structured circuits of
constant degree circuits and so on so
what I want to do now is explain how we
construct these zero knowledge proof son
distributed data by introducing this
object called a fully linear PCP or a
fully linear IOP and then I'll give you
a taste of some of the constructions so
the way we construct these urinal and
proofs on distributed data is
essentially in two steps we first define
this thing called a fully linear PCP
which is a twist on standard linear pcps
that we've seen earlier this week and
then we give I guess what you've all
described is an information theoretic
compiler from fully linear PCP for a
language into a zero knowledge proof on
distributed data for the language so
then we just need to construct new
objects to feed into this compiler and
then and then we're done
so I know we've seen linear PCP before
I'm just gonna remind you again what
they are so that I can show what the
contrast is so this is a notion that was
defined by a shy cushy Leviton Ostrovsky
in no7 and has been super useful for a
number of cryptographic instructions so
the idea is a linear PCP proof pie that
attests to the fact that a vector X is
in a language this proof pie is just a
vector and the way you check this proof
is the verifier reads the input so this
is the statement that the verifier is
trying to check the X that should be in
the language and it makes a constant
number of linear queries to this proof
so a linear query is just a vector
that's as long as the proof itself and
each query the ant the answer to each
query is just the inner product of the
quarry in the proof so after say three
of these queries the linear PCP verifier
should accept the reject and there's
sort of standard notions of completeness
and soundness and zero knowledge that it
should hold in the setting so a fully
linear PCP is almost the same thing the
only difference is the verifier now no
longer has explicit access to the
statement X that is being proven instead
the verifier only gets implicit access
to the statement X through the proof
Oracle so what the verifier does is it
gets to make a constant number of
queries to the input and the proof
jointly and then has to decide whether
to accept or reject and still we should
we should get completeness and soundness
and zero knowledge
any questions about this this model the
number of pills or the support of
referring to the number of course not to
the support yes I mean okay so yeah and
we can also define the notion of a fully
linear interactive Oracle proof that's
just the interactive analogue of a fully
linear PCP so what this is is a prove or
sends you a proof you send a challenge
the prover sends you a proof you send a
challenge and back and forth many for
many rounds and at the end the verifier
makes some number of linear queries to
the input and all the proof Oracle's
combined and then has to accept or
reject so this actually naturally
captures I'm not going to go into the
details but naturally captures a number
of existing proof protocols like g'kar
and CMT can be framed in this setting of
an interactive a fully linear
interactive oracle proof so if you
consider living according to X in PI one
then you can just invert the X probably
1 and PI 2 it's also generally I know so
I'm gonna say this is a public point
protocol and I'm gonna defer all the
queries to the very end
yeah
good so now I'm gonna show that if a
language has a short fully linear PCP
then it has a low communication zero
knowledge proof on distributed data so
this is kind of the compiler and you'll
see it's it's very very straightforward
so the verifier the setting is we have
these two verifiers each verifier has a
piece of the input so this verifier has
a piece x1 this verifier has a piece x2
and the proofer has both x1 and x2 and
the proof is gonna try to convince the
verifiers that they're holding a piece
of a an X in the language so the prover
outputs a fully linear PCP that attests
to the fact that X is in the language it
splits this proof into two shares using
a secret sharing scheme like a linear
secret sharing scheme and it sends one
piece of the proof to each of the two
verifiers so now the verifiers have a
piece of the input they have a piece of
the proof and they want to simulate the
process of asking linear queries to the
input and the proof Oracle so what they
do is they use common retinas between
themselves to sample a set of linear PCP
queries and then what they can do is
they can use the fact that we used a
linear secret sharing scheme here the
publish shares of the answer to this
query that the proof Oracle would have
given so this verifier takes the inner
product of its query with its piece of
the input and the proof and this
verifier does the same thing and by
adding up these two shares of the query
answers they can reconstruct the answer
that the Oracle would have given yeah
you are considering the induced instance
to be the sum of the graphs that was
also an example
[Music]
basis and shared attitude is there any
reason why now you're moving to shared
yeah yeah I've been going back and forth
because they're essentially the same you
can from one setting to the other
without oh okay so then so then after
the verifiers do this for a constant
number of time so for each query they
can reconstruct the answers then they
just run the fully linear PCP verifier
and they accept or reject so the
communication overall here is now
proportional to the size of the the
linear PCP proof and a constant number
of extra safe filled elements for
figuring out what the Corre answers are
so once you construct this object fully
linear PCP or IOP getting to a zero
knowledge proof on distributed data is
is very straightforward I should say I
didn't I just described kind of the non
interactive version here but if you add
interaction the thing works basically
the same yeah so essentially if the
underlying fully linear PCP is honest
purifiers your knowledge then what's the
only thing that the said that malicious
verifier learns is it gets to see these
these pieces of the answers to the
queries but this is exactly what it
would have seen how to pay it honestly
so it's like it's not learning anything
by seeing the answers to the queries
from the the honest verifier through the
shares of the answers to the quarters
from the allosteric wire
do we have these yeah so I'll show them
and once again yes yes so they're not
actually sending the quarry anywhere
they're just simulating the process of
asking this quarry to the input before
call yeah so they you say a
coin-flipping protocol to agree on the
randomness they'll use them then they
fight one is supposedly random then from
there from there someday
in the product you don't learn anything
about x1 but fight one is not
necessarily completely what are you
saying so why do yeah so when I said I
kind of hid this under the rug when I
was saying we the prover splits this
proof into two pieces using a secret
sharing scheme and you can think of the
prover is sending a random string to the
first verifier and a random string - the
original proof to the second verifier so
each of these proofs independently hides
information theoretically hides the
truth
I was worried you're gonna ask about NPC
problem okay good so right so now let me
explain how you construct these fully
linear proof proof systems so maybe the
first thing to see is it's it's it's
either good news or bad news but
actually many existing linear PCPs
that people use in practice are already
fully linear so if you look at the
original construction from the ICAO
paper or GG PR style
linear pcps they already only make sort
of linear access to the verifier only
makes linear access to the input so this
is great and these things also satisfy
on as verifiers your knowledge it is
linear PCP the downside is that the
proofs are large so for a circuit of
size see the proof sizes is C over up
maybe to see something like this what we
show is you can actually get shorter
proofs for languages with structure and
this is important in our application
because the efficiency of the zero
knowledge proof on distributed data
essentially the communication grows with
the size of the proof so the shorter the
proof the more efficient protocol we get
and yeah the right way to go you have
like reductions
I haven't thought about it and I think
there could be certainly other
approaches I actually think maybe based
on MPC or other things but yeah yeah
it's a good question
that lost some state initially we we
have lower bounds in the length of a
either the universities or prominently
around
in other words
should I only expect short obesity's for
structured languages or yeah that's a
question so the question is should we
expect shorter linear pc shorter linear
PCPs for arbitrary languages or is this
linear circuit size inherent so for
standard linear PCPs I don't think we
know and I think you'd have to make some
complexity theory you'd need to make
some assumption that this is a at least
I think four fully linear PCP is it's
actually very pretty straightforward to
prove via communication complexity a
lower bound that says essentially say if
the proof size is square root then the
the communication needs to be square
root between the verifiers
and so and I think you can trade trade
one for the other so if you have a
constant number of queries then this is
the best proof size you're gonna be able
to get and the fully linear set it if
the verifier is able to read the entire
input then it's then it's less clear
because now the verify there's kind of
no information hidden from the verifier
and and yeah it's not clear anyway
quote okay and so there's a number of
ideas that sort of use I use ideas
similar to the ones that I'm going to
present yeah so what I want to do and
the time I have left is to give you some
intuition for how we construct these
fully linear PCPs so again the first
result I wanted to mention is that if
your language has a circuit of size C
then you get a zero knowledge proof on
distributed data with communication
costs order C and because of this
compiler I just showed from the
existence of fully linear PC peas with
linear size proofs which you can get
from this G GPR result this theorem
Falls but what I want to do is sketch
the construction of a fully linear PCP
with the linear size proof both if
you've never seen a fully linear PCP
before it'll give you some intuition for
how we construct them and second if
you've seen the ggp are linear PCP I
think I'm gonna present it in a slightly
different way
that's amenable to generalizations that
that we'll need for the the next result
so it's not clear app in the sense this
is unconditional no no these proofs are
not these proofs these proofs are linear
in the circuit size so if you're if
you're looking at a polynomial size
circuit the proof
yeah and you'll see I guess when I show
it the proof is it'll it'll explain why
okay so let me explain how how these
things work so say we have the following
language so I want to test that some
field element X is in the set 0 1 2 and
in a big field so this is a circuit that
computes this thing that's 0 if and only
if this is true and so what the fully
linear PCP is going to be is the
coefficients of 3 polynomials I'll call
them F G and H and each has degree
roughly the circuit size so I'll explain
how what the proof is and then I'll
explain how how we check the proof with
a constant number of linear queries the
proof is going to be these three
polynomials and I'll define them like
this so I'll let this polynomial F
essentially encode the values so all the
proof is going to take this value X and
it's going to run it through the circuit
and it's going to get the values of all
the internal wires in the circuit and
then F of F of 1 is going to be the
value on the first the left wire of the
first multiplication gate and F of 2 is
going to be the value on the second wire
or the left wire on the second
multiplication gate so F sort of
captures all the values on the left
input wires and G captures all the
values on the right input wires and then
H is just going to be F times G there's
only three polynomials constitute the
proof and if you look think about it for
a second you'll see that since H is F
times G H of 1 and H of 2 encode the
values on the output wires of the
multiplication gates in the circuit
this
anyone has a question
all right so this proof now has size
linear in the size of the circuit so now
that check the proof yeah twice that
roughly yeah yeah I'm taking the lowest
degree bottom yeah so right so now to
verify this this proof I'm the prover
gives gives me at Oracle access to F hat
G add an H hat that are supposed to
satisfy these relations and now I need
to check that these relations hold with
a few linear for use so essentially like
most of these proof systems you kind of
want to check that the proof is
consistent with the inputs so here I
want to check that say F hat of 1 is
equal to the X that I'm expecting and G
hat of 1 is equal to say X minus 1 so I
want to check all the inputs then I want
to check the output so I want to check
that H of H of 2 is 0 and then I need to
check the internal wires in the circuit
so I need to check that the Edition
gates are computed correctly these sort
of copies are computed correctly and
finally I need to check the
multiplications so it turns out all
these affine checks can be done with one
linear query I can take essentially the
linear combination of a bunch of random
linear combination of these affine
checks with one linear query I can check
all those things and then evaluating F
and G and H at a random point can can be
done with three linear queries together
so if you put all these checks together
it just requires for linear queries no
matter how big your circuit is and the
soundness is like a circuit size / field
size
and as an optimization you can actually
get rid of FNG in the proof also so this
is a very very simple and concretely
efficient construction which is why you
can use it in practice okay so for a
circuit with say M multiplication gates
yeah good good so I didn't I didn't
explain how that works but it's very
very simple
all you do is you set the constant term
say F of 0 g of 0 F of 0 and G of 0 to
be random values and and that's enough
so okay so the downside is that this
proof size grows with the size of the
circuit and this essentially this
construction I showed matches the
complexity of this G GPR style in your
PCB but even so the consequence is nice
we get a sort of a linear communication
through knowledge proof on distributed
data for arbitrary circuits getting two
smaller circuits is actually quite yeah
[Music]
those are still anyways
actually I think this is slightly
simpler it's not it's not a huge huge
difference but they see the prior prior
approaches didn't cook zero knowledge
into the fully linear PCB so you had to
add it and whatever external protocol
that you were using which is slightly
less clean
right so what you can do is if you have
your circuit has structures so say it
has a repeated gadget that's used in a
bunch of places call it G gate then the
proof size actually scales if you just
generalize the construction I just
showed the the proof size ends up
looking like the number of these g gates
times the degree of the g gate so so if
your circuit has a repeated sub circuit
and it many times and you're lucky and
that repeated sub circuit has low degree
then you get a short proof so in
particular could be sub linear in the
circuit size so it's just one kind of
toy example you can think about a
circuit for testing whether a vector has
a particular l2 norm and this has a lot
of structure and so you can get say a
square root size proof and as a result
you get a square root size or squared
communication protocol okay so the last
thing I want to mention is is how we can
get even shorter proofs for structured
languages the idea here is we use this
new fully linear PCP construction but we
kind of use interaction to recursively
outsource the verifiers work to the
prover so what it looks like is the
prover sends you a fully linear PCP but
then instead of checking it yourself you
send your random coins to the prover and
you say prove to me that I would have
accepted this proof had I checked it and
then the prover sends you a proof and
you kind of recurse all the way down
until there's a constant size thing you
can check yourself so if your circuit
has a lot of structure then it's
amenable to this kind of recursion and
it turns out that low-degree circuits do
have this structure
okay so that's what I wanted to say so
this has been about journal on crus on
distributed data and the setting of one
program will pull verifiers and the
proofs that you get our information
theoretic and super lightweight and I
hope that this idea of a fully linear
proof system made sense I think there's
a bunch of work to do and understand the
relationships between these ideas and
others I thought to Justin a little bit
about this one thing I wanted to mention
is I guess we've think been thinking a
little bit about the best of both worlds
proof systems in which you make linear
access to the input but then point point
access to the proof and it would be
interesting to kind of see how easy or
hard it is to construct those things and
I guess I'll let we'll talk about
applications
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
second Photoshop given by okay so
excellent so this is indeed the
follow-up to to Henry's talk and I'm
gonna be shifting gears a little bit so
Henry was talking about a bit about this
notion is the definition and how to
construct it and I'm gonna be talking
purely about how to use it okay
so let me start you off with a little
bit of a quick refresher hopefully you
haven't forgotten this yet but just to
remind you of so here I'm going to be
talking about really just sort of using
as a black box this notion of a fully
linear PCP okay and this is indeed where
the verifier only has linear query
access to 2x and pi together
if the careful among you may have
noticed that in Henry's X was small and
pi was relatively big I'm going to be oh
this looks precarious doesn't it
so here not not by accident I'm going to
be kind of thinking about a setting
where pi is small smaller in particular
than the input length the statements are
okay so as you saw this is interesting
and not just for things like mpa but
even for simple languages and relations
okay so for example even if X the
relation I want to show is something
like a degree two relations hold here
this is still a very non-trivial and and
powerful object and in fact so from
Henry's talk
we have constructions for for simple
certain simple classes of relations so
for example things like if you have
repeated copies of exactly the same
subcircuit you get some savings and the
one that I'm really going to be using to
today right now is just for degree two
relations of the statement ok so again
not even language here there's no
witness just some statement potentially
big and we want to to argue that it
satisfies some degree two relations ok
so I'm going to assume now that we have
a construction of such a thing that
satisfies this strong zero knowledge
again this is kind of a non-standard
term but by strong zero knowledge I mean
that the interaction these answers that
verifiers receive don't reveal anything
about okay so witness if you had a
witness but in particular about X the
statement itself okay and that the proof
size here PI is gonna be sibling urine
in the size of X okay so this is you
know this topic is this part of the talk
is gonna be about applications and
really kind of the the crux that I want
to convey here one of the reasons why is
this notion potentially interesting
because it allows you to prove things in
settings in kind of a generic way where
potentially the verifiers only actually
have linear access they don't have full
access to the input but maybe they do
somehow in one way or the other they're
able to to learn linear functions of
this thing
okay for example suppose that and then
indeed this is also copied from from
Henry's slides so for example suppose
it's the case that neither verifier
actually even knows the statement itself
X but only has pieces of it or for
example you can think about secret
chairs additive secret shares okay so in
the setting this sort of allows you to
directly translate this abstraction is
fully linear PCP in two proofs in this
kind of distributed statement setting
okay so for example I could either the
the prover can just kind of send PI over
if you want to preserve zero knowledge
you can send just some sort of additive
secret sharing of the proof pi and now
these verifiers can start to inner
interacting and running already okay and
it's so this is one this is an example
distributed data secret shared if it's
some sort of linear secret sharing
scheme then verifies again can can do
these linear pieces on there separately
to be combined also i just want to
mention i'm not gonna use this anymore
but for example if the the statement is
he's hidden maybe it's encrypted or
something like that or committed to but
you do have some sort of linear
homomorphism involved okay and just to
kind of reman ssin this was exactly one
of the slides that henry said so was
like i think that the dis setting is
something that could be very interesting
in general I mean for example you know
ideally you could think about something
maybe I want to prove something about my
health and my monetary status or
something so for example one of the
verifiers might be a bank one might be a
hospital they don't have and nobody has
the full combined statement of this but
but everybody has pieces okay and
another example of this as Henry
mentioned was is actually deployed used
in in Firefox ok so and I'm not Wow
Dwight when did I start ok well you
don't talk too fast but okay so the the
rest of the talk I'm going to be
focusing on an application of secure
computation so here this is some secure
multi-party computation I'm gonna refer
to this on and off as NPC if you see
that on the slides okay this is the
setting as you likely know where there's
a collection of parties each with some
secret inputs and some global function f
the goal is to learn the output of F on
the secret inputs but without revealing
anything else about the inputs okay and
this should hold even if some fraction
say if the parties is corrupted okay so
beautiful results feasibility results
back in the 80s we know that this is
possible for any efficiently computable
F we can do this
assuming either honest majority or
computational assumptions for this talk
I'm only going to be talking about the
honest majority case so here you can
hope to actually get information
theoretic security but I'm going to be
because I'm gonna be kind of interested
in a practical practicality people who
know me might say question that a little
bit but the I'm interested in you know
constants and things like this so we'll
toss in for example PR G's okay so the
question what about the communication
complexity okay so I want to run some
secure computation for function f and
say so do you be a bit more concrete
here suppose that f is represented with
some circuit maybe arithmetic over some
ring or boolean okay and how much
communication do we have to spend to
actually to do this securely so
for example if I didn't care about
security we could just have say sighs of
inputs plus size of outputs okay so the
answer to this question depends a lot on
who you talk to so for example in the
fairy land the the the communication
asymptotically is essentially imprecise
I've been post put plus size of outputs
okay would you know probably secured
your parameter and so forth but this is
like here this is not the sort of
protocol in general that yeah so there's
a lot of overhead so for example this is
using fully homomorphic encryption or
homomorphic secret sharing or some sort
of relatively heavy cryptographic tools
okay so now once you turn to the more
practitioner practitioner line of
research within secure computation in
practice the answer to this question
many settings is the following so say
that I have a circuit representation of
this thing then the communication is
going to be some relatively small
constant times the size of the circuit
most the time it's just the
multiplication gates okay and this is a
long line of work trying to to get this
constant down just to kind of be a
little bit more concrete about what do I
mean what am i allowing myself here for
example what separates these two let's
say for example I'm allowed blackbox
access to a pseudo-random generator but
that's really it
okay so efficiently that's not so bad
taken so zooming in a little bit more
here about this this complexity even
dating back to the original works in MPC
the structure of how to build secure
protocols almost always satisfies the
following framework okay you start by
building some sort of relatively weaker
security protocol against passive or
semi honest security
so here it's assumed that the adversary
does follow the protocol but he's trying
to learn more than he should about the
information and then you compile up to
get kind of a standard security where
here you also consider guys who are
trying to ruin your life by sending bad
messages okay so taking a little bit
more of a look on in
computation here aside communication
here in Sultan's were pretty happy with
the state of affairs down here in the
semi honest case okay we have like the
lightweight protocols alpha is one which
is pretty good and in some zoom and this
is an interesting question for debate
about whether this is inherent or
anything like that
but as far as is really we know how to
do now this is this is kind of the best
okay and the question that's I would say
less well understood is exactly this red
arrow here how to get go from semi
honest to full active security okay
so a little bit of an aside this is all
it can you can't really tell this isn't
mine really great out here I I'm
probably not gonna have much time but I
want to give you a little bit of a
flavor of some existing approaches for
this red arrow here so the original
approach going back to to gmw go right
and kali and victor sun is roughly that
the parties so suppose what what I mean
by this red arrow suppose that you have
a semi honest secure protocol how can
you now somehow enforce the parties to
act in a semi honest way and what they
did in this thing is so first they kind
of everybody had to commit to their
imports you run some sort of coin
tossing but then in the protocol in
every single message that you send you
would also accompany this with some sort
of zero knowledge proof that this was
the message you were supposed to send
okay this is actually a beautiful
compiler I'm jumping the gun a little
bit what I want to say so there's two
two maybe limitations on this compiler
one is unfortunately the overhead is
pretty high like the size of these is
your knowledge proofs and so forth and
the second is that in some settings so
here in order for this to work even it
has to be the case that that the people
everybody knew what the statement was so
I'm proving in zero knowledge that I'm
performing the next step but has to be
that people know sort of have the full
for example even just the message that
I'm sending everybody would need to be
able to see this okay so this works and
if you have a protocol over say a
broadcast channel but if you have
something that
point-to-point channels then this this
approach it's not really clear how to
proceed so maybe you know fast
forwarding about 20 minutes or so what
we provide with this folding linear PCPs
can be viewed as a form of a gmw
compiler but over a distributed setting
okay great so this is back to the
previous slide where we were and this is
the state of affairs in terms of our
alphas here this constant multiplicative
factor okay so the main results that we
give in terms of this NPC part of
applications is a new compiler a new
arrow going from passive to active
security this works not for any any
protocol but for protocols that satisfy
a particular natural structure okay
natural may be in quotes and I'll talk
about what I what this is here but the
benefit is that going from passive to
active in our compiler has only
sublinear additive communication okay so
here say you have a very big circuit
where as existing approaches required
you to now at least communicate another
copy of the circuit or more now this is
if you have some sort of alpha you know
elements required to be communicated for
party per gate in the bottom now you'll
get amortized over the circuit size
you'll get the same alpha yeah in fact
so sort of what we're going to leverage
is the repeated structure of just the
fact that you have a bunch of kind of
multiplications essentially
okay so so this is a generic compiler of
course it depends a little bit on what
this natural is how interesting
this compiler really is so let's see
applying this compiler to two existing
protocols let me tell you about some of
the things that we can achieve okay so
so one particular setting that's quite
motivated and this is what I'm gonna
focus most of my time about today is
this setting with three parties one
corruption okay again remind remember
I'm saying everything that I'm talking
about is gonna be honest majority and
the reason why people have really this
is one area I mean this is not this is
not a complete list of citations here
one of the reasons that people really
care about this is that in some sense
it's kind of the minimal they not really
but maybe the easiest setting of
performing secure computation okay so
clearly kind of you want fewer parties
makes things cheaper but going from two
to three if you if you go to three
parties with one corruption this honest
majority can really help you out in
terms of efficiency okay so comparison
and the existing results in terms of
what is and again all this is kind of
going back to what is the Alpha that you
can get this constant multiplicative
overhead depends a bit on what uh what
your ring is that your circuit is over
okay so for example if I'm over a large
field it was known how to get alpha
equals two on the other hand so so this
really leveraged the fact that you get
something like 1 over field size
soundness error so if the field is very
very large this can help you out for the
boolean case if I start with the boolean
circuit the best that we knew how to do
was alpha equals 7 okay this is you know
after a lot of authors a lot of papers
and you know a lot of these things in
some sense you require a lot more work
and clever ideas than what we do which
may be a good thing
in any case using this compiler we can
now get this alpha down to one so really
it is just additive sub when you're
overhead from the the semi honest with
this light weight and alpha equals one
okay another mention here so this
this is not only alpha equals one but
this actually works so we can run this
even with small fields and so not not
quite general rings but anything of the
form Z n for any end that you like and
it kind of salt treat I'll discuss this
a little bit so I'll touch on a little
bit later of how can we do that but
really though the one sentence broad
stroke is that because we have this sub
linear communication that we have to add
we can really be very sloppy in terms of
things like you know embedding or
multiplicative constant over overhead
factor of that thing cuz it's still sub
linear okay whereas in these ones people
really had to be very careful of making
sure that there was no sort of waste
anyway okay so so this is the core that
I'm gonna talk about we do have we can
extend this as you'll see at the very
end it takes quite a bit more work but
what we can achieve is so for any
constant number of parties with honest
majority anything honest majority so
beforehand over a large field the best
was say three alpha equals three once
you go to boolean the the situation
became much more questionable something
around 40 and again so so here we're I
mean we're not at one you do they want
something like this but this is again
matching the the best agree for the best
semi honest okay so this this skills
when T when if you plug in T equals one
N equals three that that matches this
and it gets slightly worse as n gets
bigger but it's still bounded by one
point five good so the computational
complexity is still quite reasonable
it's it's higher but it's still
certainly in any sort of setting if your
bandwidth limited or like even a
reasonable bandwidth limited there's
some sort of trade-off
the capital end here or Oh little n so
just like it so remember that alpha is a
number of elements per party per gate is
that ah good good good good
so here this is in order to and yeah I'm
not gonna be able to go into it so this
is compiling the base protocol is down
the road Nielsen protocol and there in
order to get even the semi honest
version down to 1.5 you have to do some
tricks with like a bunch of the secret
Cheers you send out or actually
generated by pseudo-random generator and
then in order to do that with low like
communication then the it blows up kind
of exponentially in the number of
parties I'd be happy to work it out
later on yeah so here it's it's the
computation starts growing poorly within
and in fact actually that's probably a
good thing to point out so here because
of that there is also some sort of sweet
spot that like if n is it gets pretty
big I would not recommend this as a
practical protocol because of the
computation
okay so for the rest of the talk which
I'm clearly not going to be able to to
do
okay so I kind of ideally decided to go
through and describe to you a passive
secure protocol and then show how we
build on top event maybe if the chairs
aren't paying attention I'll go for it
okay hmm okay so I'm this feasible okay
so I'm gonna do this really quickly if
you don't follow I apologize but I
probably should keep going and I'm happy
to go through it in more detail
afterward for anyone who's interested
okay so let me start with one of the
passive secure protocols that fits this
sort of natural natural property which
are all kind of semi define that allows
us to build on top of it okay and this
is going to be based on for those who
know it's like a replicated secret
sharing protocol okay so we've got our
three parties the first step is each
party will secret share their inputs
how will they secret share their inputs
well this is not just going to be
additive secret sharing so this is kind
of the first thing say that I have my
secret a I'll first generate additive
shares of it but I'm going to give these
shares not just to one person each but
each each share will be held by two
people okay so here the shares are say a
1 a 2 a 3 that add to a but everybody
has two or three shares ok next in the
same sort of fashion will generate sets
of shares of this form but of 0 okay so
I'm in the same sort of way now suppose
that this is the gate that we want to
evaluate we're gonna take these shares
that we have and gate by gate do some
sort of step ok so note that this is
already this is a linear secret sharing
scheme so any sort of addition gate we
can just do locally on the individual
shares and in regard to multiplication
so note here that each so what do we
really need say I want to multiply I
have two wires one is supposed to hold a
one is supposed to hold B we have these
shares of these values to generate
shares of the product or even to sort of
reconstruct the product you need all of
the three squared cross terms okay but
we're in good shape because each person
or rather so each pair of these terms is
actually held already by some party okay
so let me draw this out so say these are
the three parties remember for example I
have these you have these the third guy
has Z's so what each of us is going to
be able to do is to generate three of
the nine cross terms locally these
actually now satisfy the property that
these are additive shares of the product
okay they're not random additive shares
so we'll use the shares of zero to mask
these to get to make them fresh additive
shares so this now I'm representing by
it by these values and now the only
thing you have to do is we have to get
back to this replicated state but this
really just requires that I send my
share to one other guy you send your
share to somebody else and so forth okay
so this is kind of one one communication
of an element per gate per party yes yes
okay men and finally so once we reach
the output gate we all have this kind of
share of the output all you have to do
is everybody sort of sends each other
their shares and we can reconstruct okay
so a couple different things let's start
by taking a look at the communication
here so if you if you take the protocol
as it is and you actually do these
shares and everything with random values
this is actually even information
theoretically secure okay but we want to
try to drop the communication down and
I'm allowing blackbox access to a
pseudo-random generator so this allows
you to to do very tricks for example now
these things he sets like lots of secret
ears of zero well what are these things
are sort of a bunch of random values
where people have certain people have
copies of the same random values you can
compress these random values say with
the PRD or PRF so amortized this is
actually even going to go away okay and
what you're left with so this is also
kind of for example some of these other
things are
the drug using some pseudo randomness in
order to compress things down for
example it can always be the case that
two of the shares are random and the
third one just has to kind of add up to
the right thing this allows you to save
on communication
okay so ultimately this gives you one
element per party per per gate I guess
you also have the one pretty important
one per output okay so some observations
about this protocol it starts giving
this in shape here the first thing is
this secret share of the inputs so
remember what was this everybody had to
to to take their input shared in these
pieces and send it out in this form give
incorrect values here this already
implicitly defines an input for the
adversary so what he's given why because
if these two guys are honest we have a
copy of a one-way of a copy of a tuning
of a copy of a three we can extract the
influent okay so what he sends it
commits him to an input another
observation above this line everything
that the adversary this corrupt party
sees is total random garbage okay this
is actually you'd have to think about it
some but this is even if even if people
are acting maliciously and so forth this
basically this is some sort of you know
secure evaluation of some sort of empty
function so if you don't send these less
messages the adversaries learned nothing
okay
another observation in the final round
of this protocol so what did we do
everybody just sent out their shares of
one of these replicated secret sharing
values this is robust in the following
sense okay so say that Y was the value
that we that we had here and so given
given one party I guess now I have it
the corrupt guy you expect to get the so
what is sort of the missing value here
you're getting two copies of the same
thing from the other two parties okay so
this actually makes more sense if I'm
looking in the other direction so
honest guy gets shares from the other
two people and the ones there's one
share that he doesn't know this is this
is really what's giving him the
information of the final output and the
point is that he's expecting exactly the
same value from the two parties this is
important because if for example the
adversary decided to change his share to
some garbage this would be identifiable
okay so here are robust shares of the
output in the final round and the final
thing is that if it's the case that
these really are sort of correct
additive shares of zero that are
generated here and if so remember that
there was some sort of operation for
each multiplication gate you were
supposed to do some you had some shares
from previous you were supposed to
multiply them in a particular fashion
add them up and then send something out
if you performed that step correctly if
each and every one of those steps was
performed correctly then you sort of
trickling through the circuit you have
the property that the thing you compute
these shares at the very end really is
the circuit evaluated on the inputs okay
and in fact this this piece here is
exactly so sort of the combination of
these two is how you prove security
exactly how you prove security of this
protocol in the passive adversary model
so here this allows you to say that
nothing's leaked and then at the very
end so in the very end you're guaranteed
that this really is correct because so
you don't have to do anything here this
holds already because you're assuming
the guys acting semi honestly but he's
following the protocol then you can kind
of simulate the final round message
given here okay so these things are
going to be the natural properties that
our protocol need that our compiler
needs okay so if you have any protocol
and in fact this is actually a very
common structure a lot of protocols if
you kind of look around in literature do
have this sort of form so if you have
this package of properties then our
compiler will apply
to you okay good so maybe maybe to try
to kind of give you a little bit of
intuition I'm actually not gonna dive
into very much detail but again so why
why is this going to be useful actually
let me let me go for it okay so here is
going to be the compiler and in fact
maybe you'll even started thinking about
this at this point so remember this is
the structure forget about the protocol
itself
I'm assuming it's some natural protocol
that had the properties from the
previous sign that means that there's
some initial part PI prime without the
final message and this final message
okay what we're going to do you ready
for this is the most elaborate animation
I'm going to have here right there okay
squeezing in there are no the new
protocol will run this without a change
okay identically this PI prime okay but
before sending the final message the
parties are each going to prove to each
other okay and zero knowledge that they
really did follow the protocol up to
here that each step that they made each
message followed what they were supposed
to do okay to be honest this is not a
new framework this is you know basically
what you would expect and in fact there
are other protocols that have similar
approach here but sort of the power or
maybe what's with snow here in this work
is that we give away this folding liner
PCPA and proofs on distributed data
directly give you a way of doing this
and in fact with small communication
okay so ah yeah so first of all if any
party is rejected here you abort and
otherwise you do exchange the final
message
okay so zooming in a little bit more on
on this box here would white what really
is gonna be happening so why is that
this proofs on distributed data is
exactly in line with this so what I'm
trying to prove okay so think of I'm I'm
one of the three parties here I'm trying
to prove that everything I did up above
was exactly what I was supposed to do
okay so the statement
it is just think about the appending
every single message that I sent out or
received in during the protocol okay so
neither of you two has this statement in
full okay but each of you kind of by
definition has a part of the statement
such that if you bring them together you
would have exactly all the messages that
were sent in or out during the protocol
okay and what I need to assert is that
this collection of messages satisfies
the particular degree to relation bingo
this is exactly what what we have and so
here this is example one of the simple
relations we have these folding linear
PCPs with sub linear size proofs so that
means that the communication that we're
gonna have to have here in order to
prove to you guys I basically have to
additively secret sure this proof send
it out but this is going to be sublinear
in the the size of the circuit that we
were computing gave just kind of one
small note here the soundness if you
just apply this directly the soundness
will error will be something like one
over the field size or the the ring size
that you're working with in the circuit
but as I mentioned before that's okay
because we can actually embed directly
so all of the the PI prime the protocol
itself has done say over the boolean
whatever now only for the part of the
proof will embed this into some sort of
bigger structure so that we can get
small sum this error okay and it's still
going to be sub linear in the circuit
side okay so just kind of putting these
pieces together again our new protocol
you run the original protocol except for
the the final message each of the
parties will probe to the other two in
this distributed manner that they
performed their steps correctly and and
then if so then you're sort of safe to
to exchange the final message
okay yeah yeah no this is yeah this is
already a wrap-up slide so the only goal
of this slide is to to get you intrigued
by the more than three party case to put
a couple challenges so the first
challenge and this came up a lot in
questions in the in henries part so up
until now in the three party case you
have this very convenient setting three
parties one corruption where either the
prover is malicious or one of the
verifiers
is malicious okay but if you have more
parties you can have and in particular
more corruptions you can have the case
for example where malicious prove err in
verifier could be colluding with each
other and here it really actually opens
up a lot of interesting questions even
for example defining soundness becomes a
little bit tricky and in order to
achieve it this requires that whatever
the statement is is somehow robustly
encoded across the different verifiers
okay so that's great but then because of
this robustness requirement turns out so
this this transformation becomes more
tricky because that's no longer the case
so before it was the case that my
statement X was just the messages going
in and out here but at this point this
is not a robust statement it only
becomes robust in this case if you also
include messages going between the other
people so it's no longer the case that
the prover actually no even knows the
full statement he has to prove something
about okay so here and we end up using a
different structure for the compiler I'm
not going to tell you about it but feel
free to ask me about it afterward okay
so just to sum things up fully linear
pcps have a lot of really interesting
applications improving on statements
where you don't have this statement in
hand but you somehow have say linear
access to it okay there's one example of
this we have a new compiler going from
passive to active security in MPC so I'm
already massively over time I think I
won't spend time about future directions
let me just very briefly so here clearly
for multiple parties dishonest majority
is a whole different cat
forms and one last mention so the the
active security notion that's achieved
in the previous transformations is
security with abort so for example if
somebody's rejected you abort you could
hope to try to get in the setting full
security full a little security together
with output and guaranteed output
delivery and that's what I mean by full
security so we do in the case the
specific case of three parties we have a
follow-up work together so this is
together with me eval and re enough that
does achieve this but the end party case
seems a lot more tricky than three party
so there's interesting places to go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]